a man police say LED several agencies on
a high-speed chase from Boulder City to
Las Vegas skip court on similar charges
just months ago the a news now
investigators have learned that
37-year-old Jeffrey Hare now facing
three counts of kidnapping and reckless
driving from this incident on the 23rd
of June Metro Police wound up shooting
him he is recovering in the hospital a
court date now set for the 5th of July
the eight news now investigators also
learning that hair was the alleged
driver in a January third incident which
led to a multi-state Chase he was
accused of hitting a trooper and having
methamphetamines additionally he was
cited twice for speeding in one night
that happened in July of 22 with North
Las Vegas Police saying hair was driving
faster than 100 miles per hour